here we go again Sony have revealed the
offerings for PS Plus subscribers during
the month of May 2018 while six of the
following games will be available to
download from Tuesday the first of May
with three of them playable on your ps4
so if y'all ready let's do this starting
with those headline titles on
PlayStation 4 first up is beyond two
souls the best way to describe this is
by calling it an interactive drama
following in the veins of heavy rain
first released in 2013 you fill the
boots of Jodie Holmes who possesses
supernatural powers one of those
abilities is to communicate with a lost
soul named Aiden who you will also
control during the story the narrative
jumps around in time and goes from
awkward love scene to full-on
action set piece all with a science
fiction element underneath oh and it's a
David cage game so expects multiple
versions to each element of the story
allowing for countless endings to be
uncovered some will give you
satisfaction and closure and others will
leave you feeling bloody depressed but
that's all depends on how much you
invest into the characters if you care
for them the story will pull you in if
you don't then you won't enjoy this the
reviews for this one are all over the
place ranging from five out of ten from
Destructoid to nine out of ten from
GameSpot so give it a download and
decide for yourself and if you're
interested in the upcoming Detroit
become human then I implore you to try
beyond two souls as it's the same
developer and is the same type of game
trying it please let us know your
thoughts in the comments next we have
rayman legends this is the polar
opposite to be on two souls as you
platform your way through this cartoony
world of Raymond and his motley crew if
you haven't played a Rayman game before
don't let the visuals put you up this
game is simply brilliant ok so the plot
isn't or inspiring but there's enough
there to keep you coming back over the
course of about 13 hours you'll learn
the basics of freerunning but the second
you perfect it Rayman legends introduces
a new element and guess what
the second you master that element it
throws another one at you the boss
fights break up the core gameplay
brilliantly and the level design keeps
the game feeling fresh the
though has to be the simultaneous four
player co-op running through the level
helping or hindering each other
propels the game beyond the confines of
a solo story outrunning your friend and
forcing them off the screen is damn fun
and a great way to decide who does the
washing-up that evening the reviews for
Rayman legends are stellar with nine out
of ten under buff from many review sites
simply said if you missed this five
years ago grab it now over on the ps3 is
risen three Titan Lords this is an
action role-playing game the highlight
of this RPG is living the pirate life
you'll be making friends warning off
demons and running countless errands the
voice acting is rather impressive but
it's the beasts and the animals you
encounter that make this world worth
exploring there's not much else to
really say about risen 3 if you download
leave Lords of the Fallen a few months
back you already have a better casual
action RPG the only thing that this does
better than other games is the pirate
life
the average reviews are around 6 out of
10 is this one for you please let us
know
next is each them if you've ever played
rampage back in the 90s this may appeal
to you this game is about destruction
wrecking entire cities and counting the
cost of the taxpayer
there's a pretty cool weapon upgrade
mechanic which allows your limbs to be
adapted to cause more chaos eat them is
massively repetitive but it's a great
way to unwind without smashing up your
own belongings Metacritic has this one
at 65 out of 100 over on the Vita we
have King oddball which is also playable
on the ps4 and PlayStation 3 let's cut
to the chase it's a mobile game in which
you smash things with boulders there's
120 levels and the handful of secret
ones to find - and it'll net you 15 PSN
trophies I'm sorry I can't think of a
way to sell this one so let's not bother
moving on and finally game 6 for the
month is Furman's a modern day take on
the lemmings series you'll be herding
these little fermions and attempting to
get them into the basket this is a
strategy game so your ability to plan
during the setup stage is essential it
was first released on iPhone so don't
expect any deep mechanics but it is
surprisingly playable so there you go
that's may in a nutshell what are you
grabbing this month for me it's all
about the ps4 titles I'm going to
annihilate my family on Rayman and then
it's
- playthrough of beyond two souls again
in the hopes of getting an ending which
doesn't make me cry thanks to all three
of you who stuck around until the end I
salute you I imagine from PlayStation
grenade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]